pause this video and see if you can find
the area of this triangle and I'll give
you two hints recognize this is an
isosceles triangle and another hint is
that the Pythagorean theorem might be
useful all right now let's work through
this together so we might all remember
that the area of a triangle is equal to
1/2 times our base times our height they
give us our base our base right over
here is our base is 10 but what is our
height our height would be let me do
this in another color our height would
be the length of this line right over
here so if we can figure that out then
we can calculate what 1/2 times the base
10 times the height is but how do we
figure out this height well this is
where it's useful to recognize that this
is an isosceles triangle and isosceles
triangle has two sides that are the same
and so these base angles are also going
to be congruent and so and if we drop an
altitude right over here which is the
whole point that's the height we know
that this is these are going to be right
angles and so if we have two triangles
where two of the angles are the same we
know that the third angle is going to be
the same so that is going to be
congruent to that and so if you have two
triangles and this might be obvious
already to you intuitively or look I
have two angles in common and the side
in between them is common it's the same
length well that means that these are
going to be congruent triangles
now what's useful about that is if we
recognize that these are congruent
triangles notice they both have a side
13 they both have a side whatever this
length blue is and so and then they're
both going to have a side length that's
half of this 10 so this is going to be 5
and this is going to be 5 how was I able
to deduce that you might just say oh
that feels intuitively right I was a
little bit more rigorous here where I
said ideas these are two congruent
triangles then we're going to split this
10 in half because this is going to be
equal to that and they add up to 10 all
right now we can use the Pythagorean
theorem to figure out the length of the
blue side or the height if we call this
H the Pythagorean theorem tells us that
H squared plus 5 squared is equal to 13
squared h squared plus 5 squared plus 5
squared is going to be equal to 13
squared is going to be equal to our
longest side our hypotenuse squared and
so let's see 5 squared is 25 13 squared
is 169 we can subtract 25 from both
sides to isolate the eight squares so
let's do that and what are we left with
we are left with H squared is equal to
these cancelled out 169 minus 25 is 144
now if you're doing it purely
mathematically coh could be plus or
minus 12 but we're dealing with the
distance so we'll focus on the positive
so H is going to be equal to the
principal root of 144 so H is equal to
12 now we aren't done remember they
don't want to just figure out the height
here they want us to figure out the area
area is 1/2 base times height
well we already figured out that our
base is this 10 right over here let me
do this in another color so our base is
that distance which is 10 and now we
know our height our height is 12 so now
we have to compute 1/2 times 10 times 12
well that's just going to be equal to
1/2 times 10 is 5 times 12 is 60 60
square units whatever our units happen
to be that is our area